at this altitude I can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking and I all see the personal
question
now I receive I'm a cybernetic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
ladies and gentlemen thank you for
tuning in this episode is a follow up in
an experimental episode each of these
interviews they're typically interviews
consists of me trying to deconstruct a
world-class performer whether they be an
investor a chess prodigy an athlete or
otherwise to pull out the tips and
tricks that you can use a recent episode
that with Pavel taught suelen who is an
elite physical training instructor he's
been involved with training the fitness
the elite Soviet Special Forces units
also the Marine Corps Secret Service
Navy SEALs he did an episode that ended
up being a masterclass in strength
training and it was so popular that we
decided to do a round two and this round
two and both of these can be listened to
independently consists of the most
popular 15 questions as voted up by
hundreds of you so hundreds of you
submitted questions voted on them the
top 15 which cover just about everything
you can imagine are those that Pavel
will be answering in this episode one
piece of housekeeping if you are looking
for business mentorship in 2015 and you
would like an all-expense-paid trip to
Necker Island that's Sir Richard
Branson's private island on a private
jet to be mentored by yours truly Sir
Richard Branson and a handful of other
folks you can get all of the details and
they are very cool details at Shopify
comm forward slash Tim that's Shopify
comm forward slash Tim and if you missed
the first interview with Pavel you can
search his name PA ve L and my name and
it will be one of the first few results
on Google or go to 4-hour workweek comm
/pha
PA ve L I'll spell that and you can find
everything including all the links and
resources mentioned in that episode
without further ado here is round to the
QA by popular demand with pavel south
schoolin ladies and gentlemen it is my
pleasure to be speaking to Tim Ferriss
his audience again you have asked me a
number of questions excellent questions
and I will answer some of them today
many of the questions had to do with
nutrition it is not my specialty so I
will not be answering them with one
exception the question by Carl from
Indiana on the podcast you asked Pavel
if he had tricks regarding the
challenges of eating for hypertrophy and
he said he would mention them but you
guys never had time to circle back
well Carl to put on muscle it's a very
costly preposition for your body to put
it on it to keep it it takes a lot of
energy it takes a lot of plastic
resources and the body is very reluctant
to add muscle especially past a certain
point so you must convince it that food
is not only available the food is
abundant the food is overly abundant so
the tactic used by number of lifters top
lifters like Kirk Kowalski to get
themselves past his sticking point and
keep putting muscle on was to add a
feeling in the middle of the night
that's right you just get some food a
solid food or liquid food high-protein
food on your nightstand something that
you would mind gagging down and in the
middle of the night you just throw it
down the hatch nobody said it would be
easy and nobody said it would be health
Mikey from Dublin is wondering what is
the optimal way to combine strength
training and hypertrophy training
obviously there are many ways of doing
that
but if we were to look for the
minimalist approach simply focusing most
of your energy on doing sets of five
when you do a set of five as confirm
both by research and experience in the
trenches gives you the best of both
worlds
delivers muscle and delivers strength
far to you Mikey and muscle two
the next question is from and pardon me
if I'm not pronouncing them correctly
Josue ledesma from New York City what
would be the 80/20 training method to
build strength and overall fitness
the answer is without any doubt correct
kettlebell training when one tries to
develop all Fitness components strength
endurance flexibility power using the
same modality usually he ends up with a
whole lot of compromises but the
kettlebell when used correctly for some
reason allows you to avoid this problem
and develop all this components to a
high level we even have an expression in
the kettlebell world the what the hell
effect let's say that you're doing
callable exercises and suddenly you go
out and test yourself at something have
not been practicing and it turns out you
can do more pull-ups you can walk where
they have your weight much faster you
can lift have your weight off the ground
that's the what the hell effect and
there are a number of Soviet studies in
the 80s confirming that and in the last
several years there have been a number
of studies done in the West as well and
you can find them and PubMed now
speaking of specific training program I
recommend three highest yield exercises
that also have the steepest learning
curve they are the one arm swing they
get up and the goblet squat just do this
reaction sizes that were referred to as
a program minimum every day and I
guarantee that you're going to get a
great return on your investment
the next question is from JDK from San
Francisco you mentioned the podcast that
prior to strength training you need
proper alignment I struggled with this
one side is shorter than the other and
weaker than the other what can I do
dicey and what steps should I take first
I will find the sport sports doctor or
chiropractor who is an athlete and a
lifter and works with athletes and
lifters it's a very important step my
personal rule is I would never go to a
chiropractor who deadlifts less than I
do and after that I suggest that you
find yourself an FMS certified
specialist FMS or functional movement
screen you can read about it in the
4-hour body Gray Cook is the author and
it's a terrific system for assessing
your symmetry and helping you improve
your performance Jeffery John from
Edmonton Alberta is writing any tips for
developing conditioning are appreciated
let's start with efficiency that means
posture and relaxation if your head is
sticking forward your running speed and
endurance is going to be compromised the
same thing can be said about your gas in
the ring so work on your posture
relaxation in the Soviet Union it was as
standard practice for all kids in grade
school to practice relaxation exercises
and it's the same practice that stayed
with all the athletes all the way to the
Olympics so these exercises are very
simple they pretty much mean shaking
your muscles out so start shaking your
arms shaking your legs vibrating and
imagine that you're trying to shake
water off your limbs and practicing
these exercises regularly between sets
of your strength exercises during your
athletic practice is going to go a very
long way towards making it more enduring
and making it faster as well a
particular type of running is going to
help you with being more relaxed and
more enduring just go out on a run
without looking at the clock and focus
on being as relaxed as possible and go
as far as possible
while being as relaxed as possible and
as you keep doing that eventually all
you'll have to do is just add some gas
and you're going to run faster next item
would be strengthening your respiratory
muscles or breathing muscles research
tells us that the metabolites from your
respiratory muscles which means all the
waste products from this muscles makes
the blood vessels in your limbs get
constricted so think about it this way
you start sucking wind and then as if it
wasn't bad enough already you get this
extra punishment of the plumbing in your
legs
start shutting down
so the same research tells us that
strengthening your respiratory muscles
is going to increase your endurance by
preventing this reflexive
vasoconstriction how do we do that in
our kettle bell practice we do something
called the biomechanical breathing match
so let's say we're performing a set of
swings on the way down we sharply inhale
into the abdomen through the nose so
you're inhaling against the resistance
of your muscles and against the
resistance of the weight and on the way
up
you're forcefully exhaling as if you're
striking that's called the bio
mechanical breathing match so that's how
we strengthen our breathing muscles then
there is such a thing is the breathing
discipline breathing ladder is a very
effective technique developed both on my
colleagues Reb Lawrence let's say that
you're doing a set of swings kettlebell
swings or a sprint any type of an
exercise that makes you gassed decide
that you're going to rest from this set
to the next according to a certain
number of breaths so let's say you get
to do five breaths until the next set
and this is going to discipline you to
slow your breathing down
so your physiology down stop panicking
that's also going to help with your
endurance one more thing to say is you
can develop mitochondria in your fast
twitch fibers which is going to enable
them to be much more enduring to be able
to use oxygen in the podcast I already
mentioned building up slow fibers that
already come equipped with mitochondria
but you can also build this mitochondria
oxygen using mitochondria into the
existing fast fibers so how do we do
that we do that by exerting the muscles
very powerfully for a very short period
of time typically 10-15 seconds
and after that resting activity for a
fairly long time so rest work to rest
ratio maybe as as high as one to five or
even one to six that might mean that you
would do 10 second effort followed by 50
seconds of rest seems quite easy but
until you realize that you have to
maintain that power output every time
very high maximum power output and you
have to do this up to eventually up to
40 sets
that's another the protocols by
Professor silly enough so rest actively
between this sets which means kind of
move around jog lightly shake your
muscles out the way I told you to do
this earlier and you can do this a
couple times a week or eventually you
can even do this possibly every day
Tyler EHC from new jersey is asking you
talk a bit in the interview with Tim
about how important it is in exercise
sports in life to be able to switch
yourself on and off what are your
favorite techniques for making this
rapid efficient and achievable by anyone
it's true that most people exist between
the on and the off switch they're unable
to really turn on to put out high power
they are now unable to really switch off
and enjoy some rest or just have some
endurance so there are several things
that you can do one I already mentioned
is those relaxation exercises fast and
loose exercise just shake your limbs
technique that you could use is it's an
old technique called Jacobson's
progressive relaxation training it
pretty much means lying down and then
progressively tensing all your muscles
and then relaxing them in in a
particular order that makes you aware
the tension and then makes you release
the tension throughout the day and
during your training you should be
particularly where your facial tension
because that takes a lot of effort and
it does drain you so be impassive
meditation breathing exercise from yoga
from cafe and so on definitely very
helpful when it comes to turning
yourself on the first thing you can do
is do a proper set of morning exercises
so that's researched decades ago
established that if you do a pleasant
non exhausting series of exercises in
the morning just some sort of
calisthenics joint rotations arm swings
whatever you will accelerate you will
accelerate your ability to perform at a
high level by a couple hours so you will
reach that peak of performance early in
the morning as opposed to waiting for it
later and later throughout the day your
ability to access that performance so
it's going to be greater as well back to
breathing practices there are some
special exercises and some oriental
practices like catheters the Ibuki
breathing that helps you to turn
yourself on get some more power get some
more aggression I strongly recommend one
book to you the book is called psych by
dr. Judd by solo dr. Judd by a solo by
his own admission looked like an 11 year
old stamp collector and yet he proceeded
to become one of the most successful
power lifters in history at the age of
44 after a back surgery he squatted over
600 pounds at body weight of 132
which is absolutely amazing and he
achieved that ability largely through
his mental training job reached the
point where he would wait for his
attempt as other lifters are waiting for
their attempts job would be just
sleeping and then just couple minutes
before the attempt his coach would wake
him up he would get up he would work
himself into a frenzy
he would go out lift a record and then
just go back to sleep now that's an
amazing control of your on switch and
your off switch the title of the book
again is psych by dr. Judd by Soto spell
B I a s o TT o Josh l buzz from Montreal
is asking what's the quickest way to
improve a strict barbell military press
from 3/4 of your body weight to body
weight given that my grip and abs are
already strong
Russia weightlifters have a saying to
press a lot you must press a lot the
press responds exceptionally well to a
high volume of training what does it
mean typically 20 to 50 reps per session
3 times a week that's a lot of presses
all these presses are done in low
repetitions 1 to 5 more typical two
three and four but one to five that's
the range and you never go to a failure
so typically you stay with 1/3 to 2/3 of
your max reps so what does it mean it
means that if you're able to do 10 reps
with that weight you should really only
be doing 3 to 6 repetitions so one more
time to press a lot you must press a lot
could you elaborate a neurological
strength please asks reimagine yes from
Miami Florida think of your muscles as a
6-cylinder engine and right now you are
firing only on three cylinders you could
get stronger by adding several more
cylinders and that would be hypertrophy
or you could fix that engine and learn
how to take advantage of the cylinders
you already do have that's the essence
of neurological strength training pretty
much what you do is you learn how to
activate your muscles more intensely
it's done by training with lower
repetitions is done by training with
heavier weights it's done by a perfect
practice approaching your training not
as a workout but as a practice NIC M
from Erie Pennsylvania is asking in the
podcast it's mentioned that to build
strength you shouldn't go to failure how
do you know want to add more weight if
you're not going to failure and Kellen
from Denver as a similar question you
need to use your perceived rate of
exertion so on the scale of one to ten
let's say that your typical set takes
you eight units of effort and you're
staying with this weight and a couple
weeks from now lifting the same weight
takes six or seven units of effort you
know that you've gotten stronger
kid from San Francisco is asking what is
the best way to gain strength as you get
older
bubbles book power to the people
espoused heavy lifts but going on 39
years old I'm finding that this routine
is way all-caps
way too hard on my joints step 1 go get
your joints checked by a doctor step 2
get your head in the right place my
father is 77 years old and he is dead
lifting or 400 pounds without a belt and
he does not think himself as old Dylann
from Los Angeles is wondering when does
the five minute rest between sets apply
when does it not there are three types
of rest intervals there is ordinary
stress and stimulating an ordinary
interval allows you to pretty much
recover your performance level by the
time the next set rolls around and
that's roughly three to five minutes a
stress interval accumulates fatigue so
the more sets you do the more tired you
get and finally a stimulating interval
allows you to perform better in the next
set and then may take 12 minutes or so
so unless your training program says
otherwise just go with the ordinary
interval about three to five minutes
Trey from Denver Colorado is asking the
army still has sit-ups on the physical
fitness test any advice and training and
maximizing the repetitions
first get your abs strong really strong
that means three to five sets of three
to five reps with three to five minutes
in between of an exercise that puts a
lot of tension on your abdominal muscles
that could be strict hanging leg raises
that can be the abdominal wheel that can
be strict weighted situps
so once you've gotten that strength then
just do a very minimal practice of your
repetitions set up test and you'll have
no problem swosh from Columbus Ohio is
asking I know the deadlift is one of the
best exercises but I've gotten terrible
back spasms from doing it is it my form
can I have proximate the deadlifts
effects with something else that doesn't
possibly injure me step one see a doc a
lifting doc find out what your
restrictions and limitations are either
you will learn that you can deadlift
with proper form possibly with some
corrective exercises or you have to look
for an alternative if the answer to the
deadlift is yes then find a coach a good
par lifting coach and learn how to do it
right if the answer is no ask your
doctor for some other suggestions
ask your doctor Bob the kettlebell swing
very often people who are not able to
lift heavy barbells are able to safely
do the kettlebell swing hfv k from
norway who appears to be a personal
trainer is asking how would you go about
building the discipline required to be
great in a client
stop treating people your training as
clients hair salons have clients a
client is somebody who's passively
receiving a service you want them to
think of themselves as students and you
want to treat them as students Tim thank
you for having me on your show ladies
and gentlemen
bar to this episode of the Tim Ferriss
show is brought to you by 99 designs 99
designs is the world's largest online
marketplace of graphic designers and I
have used 99 designs for years including
to get cover concepts for the 4-hour
body which went on to become number one
New York Times number one Wall Street
Journal it was a huge hit and here's how
it works
and you can check everything out
including some of my competitions you
can see these book covers and so on at
99designs com forward slash Tim whether
you need a logo a car wrap a web design
and app a thumbnail a t-shirt whatever
you go to 99 designs calm you describe
your project and then within a week or
less you have tons of designers around
the world who compete for your business
and submit different ideas and designs
and drafts you have an original design
that you love or you pay nothing it is
fantastic
I have used it I have mentioned it
before including in the 4-hour workweek
as a resource check it out 99designs
comm forward slash Tim and if you use
that link you'll be able to see what
I've done on the platform you will also
get $99 as an upgrade for free which
will get you more designs more
submissions so check it out and until
next time thank you for listening